[Music]
and welcome back to another episode of
the careful boys we got tesh over here
y'all hey
what's up what's up fellas how you doing
man i'm good how's everybody very good
man heard something i heard something
through the grapevine about a new movie
oh
yeah
new movie december 11th oh we got promo
let's go comedy central coming up
hot mess holiday hot best holidays this
was going so perfect i forgot what time
it's at but
if i had to guess well look it up if i
had to guess it's comedy central hot
mess hot if i had to guess
either like 9 8 central
10 9 central that's good everyone's just
dvr it watch it all right that's it one
all right guys hot mess holiday saturday
december 11th at 7 00 p.m pacific or
eastern or 9 p.m double showing even
better you love it watch it twice
is it is it diwali that's correct what's
diwali i heard it before it's the
festival of lights it's the uh hindu
celebration of good overcoming evil is
that when you do throw the fire
firecracker that's holy oh yeah that's
like more of like a spring harvest
celebration uh this is more uh lots of
firecrackers and what character you play
in there the indian guy i play an indian
guy there's many indian people in this
movie a lot of great give us a spoiler
give us one spoiler that's like not
gonna spoil it
but it's a spoiler
it's the funniest movie you'll ever see
really maybe
you're going to watch it find out you
got to watch it you're going to watch it
i know you want to make sure to watch it
twice
it says
a finance executive is dumped by her
cheating fiance during the diwali
holidays her best friend is now
determined to help her have a wild
holiday yeah
maybe
are you the best friend are you the male
best friend that's friend zoned and then
has to like spend the entire movie like
showing her
i wish i could tell you oh you just
gotta watch and find out don't you like
all my showbiz sayings don't you like
dude my old hollywood
i've been trained well by the commercial
machine
i'm sorry to tell you but you guys got a
zero on rotten tomatoes what that movie
hasn't come out yet i know that's
probably why
i was like did you rate it right now
that's a zero yeah give it give it a
rate yeah
congrats man melanie chandra serena
jindal cowpen oh [ __ ] have you have you
seen the like the final cut i have not
oh i've not i haven't seen this i've
seen a promo for this i just realized
that i got i think i got a buddy in it
his name can all do that oh yeah
yeah i know can all real canal and i are
in another movie
called definition please directed by
sujata day hopefully he'll be out very
soon oh
you got a lot coming out a lot of
secrets the funniest movie you'll ever
see
the second funniest movie you'll ever
see it's that's a dramedy so that's why
you know
there's some sad things in there is this
more just like a pure comedy a hot mess
holiday yeah it's it's like it's a
straight uh late night buddy comedy so
you guys have a good time no uh
stereotypical tropes
is it like an indian uh bridesmaids kind
of situation like that kind of comedy
with no stereotypical tropes
i would say it's very much against that
machine
very much against that machine i'm not
gonna watch it
it'll be the worst movie
if there's no
indian stuff that's like don't worry you
you're not
you're not going to see anyone getting
arranged marriage like anything like
that
i don't think there's any doctors in the
climax is there like a bollywood scene
at the end in the credits is there a
huge like major festival performance
i have normal indian friends i can watch
i want to go to the movies and watch a
pretend fake indian thing you want to
watch indian people getting scolded by
the war
does that make would that make you feel
better that's a feel-good movie right
you know the super buff 12-pack indian
dudes in movies oh my god i love those
guys
it's my favorite genre they're all oily
but bollywood's crazy man they [ __ ]
fly on elephants and stuff like that
have you guys have ever if any of you
guys seen a bollywood movie yeah
actually
do you remember
you guys dance right so like yeah have
you i've seen the indian dance films
which i love yeah i actually really like
it yeah
i like indian action movies yeah those
are the ones i've seen just the crazy
ones they're kind of crazy they're fast
and the furious sometimes they're way
crazier way crazier i don't i don't know
any of the titles to any of these movies
but i'm sure you guys have seen like the
youtube clips whatever the dude's like
on the horse and he like yeah he's like
he's like slides underneath an 18
wheeler like just straight up mario kart
slice i love those dude i like anything
with prabhu diva in it probably deva
yeah yeah he's like the michael jackson
of india yeah that's amazing
uh like george clooney of india there's
like a super like well so the shah rukh
khan
yeah yeah mortal kombat
he said george clooney of mortal kombat
he's the george clooney he's he's one of
the most him amitabh bachchan
uh they're the heartthrobs they're like
the uh they're like you know sort of the
man's man tom cruise and like you know
robert de niro meet the button's an
older generation but sharokina is the
the top dog in terms of like world fame
if i if you had is your family super
traditional or not no not at all because
my homie growing up my best friend his
grandma would always show me her midriff
did you guys do that or none of that
like yeah no like really here's the
thing it's really funny this is it's so
funny because like the the the tsar yeah
like and so they're wearing the top and
so you can she's like 85 yeah so and she
comes out like this i always wanted this
as a kid and i never had this
conversation all the time but they're
like your grandma's kind of [ __ ]
aunties
they'll just like their stomach will
hang out but if you're like a fit 25
year old and you show your belly it's
over it's like oh it's like you know you
better run someone's you're gonna get
slapped before you leave the house
because the grandma the grandma would do
it the mom would do it the sister never
did it exactly so it's got she's got
something you have to just like get to a
certain she might she
i guess if it's like once it's like oh
this is no longer i mean i don't want
you you are no longer desirable in that
way like then you start showing it i
guess when it's you know when you're no
longer a young lady and maybe a more
mature woman or maybe i don't know it
should be opposite you cover it up when
you're old and saggy and then you leave
it up and when you're young and there's
something like everybody let it rock i
think let it all rock it's not fair all
fair in love and war dude yeah dude let
him rock well i'll say this i have a lot
of uh in my parents house we have a lot
of
indian artwork lots of statues of naked
women
just standards just normal right just
like ancient art and my friends going up
they'll be like yo dude you got
you got like naked titties like in your
house and i'm like can we come over yeah
bro it's a wooden statue like can i
borrow it
i was like i have a question do you not
have the internet like what's going on
like
that's 3d though
is your family not in the midriffs my
mom
doesn't really wear like sarees at home
but not really is it like an event thing
yeah like at formal events weddings
parties
you know if she comes to work events
she'll wear indian stuff like that my
great grandma still wore kimono every
day
yeah but that was the last [ __ ]
samurai generation that was the end of
it yeah cruise generation
the end of the last samurai dude and my
dad uh
he still he still wears uh something
called a lungi
which is like kind of like a south asian
kilt oh but but you wear it it's like
just like a kind of like
sweatpants because it's obviously in
india it's hot and humid so it's just
like a cloth kind of toga you tied
around and lungi is that what you call
it
l-u-n-g-i and you usually have underwear
under that too you
i would i would assume traditionally you
don't
but like probably now keep tradition
alive yeah let it rock in america yeah i
think i'd commando if i lived in india
except if maybe if i was in the
himalayas it'd be too cold too cold
otherwise but then like if you're in a
tropical place the way i think about it
is like when i'm in hawaii i'll just
wear my board shorts and [ __ ] and i'm
not gonna wear underwear it makes my
balls too soft so this is how he like
ties it up swinging around he ties it up
and just picks it up otherwise it'll
drape to the ground
it's like a lungi
that's kind of tight that's comfortable
that's what looks like business from the
waist up and spa from the waist down
dude this guy's ready to party yeah he's
ready to do it he's not this man is on a
mission that was like damn dude
relaxing from the waist down he's like
cia at the spa from the last like two
years of like the pandemic did you were
able to pick up a bunch of gigs
that's why you have all these movies
like coming out or kind of i think the
industry itself obviously is just
bouncing back obviously the vaccines
helped a lot with that people are able
to just get back to work safely so you
are seeing an influx of projects that
are starting to hit the market and also
you know
if you're lucky enough and you have the
opportunity you're able to to write or
create during the pandemic if you have
the resources you know a lot of
animation happened a lot of video games
uh just because a lot of uh recording
from home you know i did a lot of
recording for for barbie uh during
pandemic yeah just because yeah just
because we were you you know how to do a
barbie voice i'm the voice of can dude
no way you're ken yeah that's [ __ ] i
thought we spoke
netflix barbie uh barbie dream house
adventures there's like multiple
spin-offs that's kind of the title of
the show but it's on netflix we have a
bunch of movies a bunch of series some
new stuff coming out uh this might be a
dumb question but you voicing a white
ken oh yeah baby that's what is that
that's appropriation my friend that's
kind of [ __ ] up bro taking it back i'm
taking that [ __ ] back you're taking
white man's jobs bruh that's crazy this
is like the tech industry in the silicon
valley
all the ceos are indians so you know the
whitest boy in america
dude ronald reagan or something you run
[ __ ] google you could be ken dude
imagine ronald reagan with this guy's
voice
is it you could do it you could do it
bart or jfk that'd be tight today's
video is brought to you by hello fresh
with hellofresh you get fresh
pre-portioned food delivered right to
your door so skip the trips to the
grocery store make cooking fun with
hello fresh america's number one meal
kit what's cool is hellofresh offers 50
menu and market items and you can choose
from every week including vegetarian
calorie smart and gourmet options so you
have plenty of variety that's actually
one of my favorite things about them is
depending on
what diet or what phase of training i'm
in they got me covered like if i'm in a
bulking phase i go with the gourmet get
the bomb flavors got
full everything you know and if i'm on a
diet they have the calorie smart ones
where everything is generally under 600
calories i can stay within my caloric
limits so i love that they have all that
and if my mom came and joined us we got
the vegetarian option too and they got
all kinds of food from breakfast lunch
and dinner and even stuff that you can
bake like the ginger spice cake truffles
you could do that for the holiday season
and you can have it and enjoy it with
your family and on average you save
about 65 a month if you go with hello
fresh meal kits because everything is
already pre-proportioned you don't have
to buy anything in excess compared to
going to grocery store where sometimes
they force you to buy 20 carrots at a
time when you only needed one so if
you're intimidated by cooking you don't
have to be there's an easy way to get
cooking and cook some gourmet tasty
stuff for not only you or your family or
whoever you're living with go to
hellofresh.com off the record 14 and get
up to 14 free meals that's freaking
insane that's one meal of the day for
two weeks straight or two meals a day
for one week that's a lot of food give
them a try use the code off the record
14 at
hellofresh.com hello fresh america's
number one meal kit number one so is the
voice of barbie like some black dude
played by a wonderful actress her name
is america young um america young that's
a little too appropriate considering we
got the indian guy voice in canada they
had to compensate
they're like this is the perfect one
it's like we need to balance this just
in case anybody complains about it
barbie's played by someone named america
and you recorded it at home uh yeah
recorded home i actually the first
episode that i did or the first job that
i did during the pandemic
um
i recorded an episode of barbie out of
my mom's sorry closet which she just was
like she like converted my brother's old
closet into just like she just put it
all here because it's all soundproof
just like all the indian clothes it has
all the fabric so like literally just
playing
and so it's just like a small little
closet that i could see i could put a
chair in can you can you give us one
line in the ken voice yeah yeah hey jk
news what's going on guys how's everyone
doing today oh you're such a blonde
white boy
how's the blonde white guy
i thought you were going to come out it
was your eyes and replay that or just
watch the show on netflix
i saw you in a red corvette too
i was imagining a convertible
yeah he was driving what um is there
when you're doing like voice acting is
there things that are different than
when you're like acting like they could
see your face uh you know i think sort
of
for me as an a as approaching the
characters
as an actor it's
voice over because they're not seeing
the physicality
of of uh visually of what you're
bringing to the character you really do
have to kind of um express that in in
the vocal range yeah so sometimes it
feels like oh
maybe i'm doing too much right maybe you
wouldn't do that if it was live action
because when you're watching live action
you're seeing the whole thing you're
hearing and you're seeing right uh but
when it's voice over you're you're
giving your energy to something else
and so you have to convey that so that
helps the animators that may help the
writers down the road when they're when
they're writing for the character um
also because it is a cartoon you can do
you know weird [ __ ] happens in cartoons
it's not real life so you can get away
with a lot more so as a result sometimes
you can be a little bit more uh
i don't want to say overacting but i'd
rather say just more expressive
uh you can you can paint with a little
bit more bolder colors
just because it's that's the world that
you live in it's a world of a cartoon
you know it's a little bit more
imagination i could picture you saying
that during like a voice actors
convention and someone in the audience
there is a voice acting dubber for
hentai porn
yo
i'm gonna moan harder
[Laughter]
yo bro i'll tell you this man
there you go
there you go like you gotta make it
believable you know that's true because
some of those dubs just take me out of
the world and man i'm like i can't jack
up to this why can't you talk like ken
the boys aren't squeaky enough huh but
there's an episode where ken teaches
barbie bungara because we were talking
about bungara yeah because they let me
do it that's dope
that's so cool wait so you
you they did they videotape me dancing
and then ken was that's
copy that they just did uh like motion
capture so white ken was teaching barbie
oh yeah oh that's cool
i want to see them get cancelled for
this they're like why is this white man
teaching them bhangra wait wait wait
wait wait wait the voice actor is indian
named america young wait [ __ ] the other
one
we need the indian guy
damn that's cool that's very interesting
voice acting that's cool try to you know
bring a little culture to the table and
get give give ken a little love what
else is ken t did you teach like martial
arts and [ __ ] not yet
maybe let's see
maybe in the next season what did they
do do they like
because i mean i never knew what barbie
and ken what their mission was they
never [ __ ] what's their mission
statement
they're best friends man yeah but joe
got like a villain right like what's
going on like in every story you need
g.i joe gi joe's a soldier yeah i don't
know so i mean like what do barbie and
can do like what's their thing what do
18 year olds do
in
california oh yeah but they're
passionate they're surfing all the time
yeah ken ken loves like what's the
stereo what's the story line you know
like even i mean i i i'm when i'm
watching full house i don't expect them
to [ __ ] fight crime but like
you think dj dj yeah there's a villain
there jesse con what's jesse consopolis
yeah there's jane
there's something that happens right so
like in a barbie ken show like well ever
it's a children's cartoon so there's
obviously like a story line they should
buy crime a little bit well they do they
like sometimes there's episodes where
they solve mysteries they you know i
know there's one episode uh where ken is
trying out to be the school mascot
you know okay so they got goals oh yeah
yeah i like that i like that they have
their summer vacation episodes oh let's
go get i got my job at the at the the
water park or we're we're going on
vacation or are there a cooper's
birthday it's very much will day won't
day
so the show actually does a really great
job and there's some really beautiful
moments of these kind of tender loving
like embarrassing real life moments
they've really uh done a great job the
cast and creative really done a great
job of sort of pushing barbie into the
modern world so it's it's it's actually
it's if you know for kids and parents
it's great to watch together she's kind
of like paris hilton
in what way
uh
keep going with that
i'm going to stay quiet on this one well
i think paris hilton jack barbie to be
honest like barbie came first the
original billionaire
but then paris like
went [ __ ] with it barbie's still like
wholesome because she didn't age
barbie's got 48 phds in every profession
oh yeah she does she's like every job
yeah yeah but
did the simple life does she have does
she have a dog in a small bag does she
does barbie carry so the family in the
cartoon the family has has the dogs they
have all the dogs well barbie comes from
a family yeah so you meet barbies
i know she was an independent woman and
she was old enough to buy her own things
no no she's 18 she lives at home with
her parents it's like she's in high
school oh she's giving her a backstory
her mom is i forget what they do they're
just all genius is her mom fine mom's
hot barbie's mom's i don't know that
much about barbara i feel like the
barbie world is just full of fine ass
people
dad's played uh
by uh on another asian actor fellow
asian actress right yeah greg chun
i don't know if you guys greg
chun chun yeah double check me that
please double check don't check said
greg doesn't kill me
barbie's dad yeah is also an asian dude
yes
he does a lot of voices how come i don't
want to see him
i don't know his resume as well as mine
so i can't but he's very accomplished
does that mean barbie's getting scolded
a lot and tell her her s.a.t scores
weren't as high as ken's that's
basically what happens and like so ken
is there really just because he's able
to get barbie a free kumon uh
subscription
he's a tutor there yeah that's the
season two because the new the new bugs
bunny is a filipino guy yeah he does and
he does a lot of he does a lot of
characters he washes it he does a lot is
he like what's up duck do you want the
mcdonald's
like that yeah
okay i thought he was a filipino bugs
bunny like he's just like
backyard [ __ ] you know filipino american
in the uh
yeah he's the new bugs bunny that'd be
so sick
if if it was fox bunny pockets bonnie
damn yeah we should we got we got you
know why's everything gotta be so normal
like why can't we making little
my races yeah we need to restore the
balance in the world a little bit you
know it's a little fun making everything
all normal and [ __ ] you look hot as [ __ ]
right here
let me see that camera let me see no
it's just for me
so the show's out now yeah on netflix
yeah i've got a bunch of seasons a bunch
of movies i'm about to watch barbie fall
wow
oh dude that's my [ __ ] you got
his picture like that for cause it's hot
as [ __ ] what yeah why would you save a
friend's picture like that because he
likes looking at me man what's wrong
with that no i mean like on your
screensaver though what's wrong with
that
are you are you jealous what's the
[ __ ] paris hilton over here yeah
airdrop us
airshot
watch next time you come all the way
back it's just gonna be a picture of me
this is just so sweet of you guys we
know this guy bro yeah he's ken in
barbie he's candy
and he's not white at all
when i tell people they're always there
it's always a double take they're like
excuse me and they don't want to be rude
what was the craziest reaction you got
when you told somebody that you're gonna
be ken from barbie outrage
they just punch you in the face
someone spit in my face just a protest
outside would pick a fence no it needs
to be a white guy um oh it's cultural or
when they told you you got the part did
they say it like kind of gimmicky where
they're like oh like you're going to be
ken
how about that my age
he called me i had done a job from
mattel before where i played
um just like barbie's friend i think you
say barbie's car
i play barbie i play barbie yeah
i played barbie's friend he was just
like an indian dude that lived down the
street looked like me so i was just
excited i was like oh this is cool yeah
this is cool and so then they called me
in they were like hey do you want to
audition for ken and i was like
okay like you know i mean like sure i'm
not gonna
that's funny
you wanna be kidding me
how do i sound now
and so i was like all right
i don't think it's going to go my way
but this is a great opportunity i was
trying to break into voiceover at the
time yeah
um
i sent in a tape
didn't hear for like a month
just forgot about it it's always like
that huh my agent calls me and he's like
yo dude uh got some great news and i'm
like oh [ __ ] what did i book i'm
thinking it's some cartoon or some video
game
that i did last week
he's like you're gonna be the
next ken
and i was like
and it was just silent
i was like what
time
that's pretty crazy that's a big [ __ ]
it was like i was like all right man if
that's
what they want to do i'm down then the
rest is history and it's been a really
really really great experience the the
cast and crew
uh we've done so much together so many
stories and i think we've really kind of
pushed the brand forward and the show is
just a lot of it's just i wish you
wanted it more man i'm disappointed with
that story i wish it wasn't so dalat i
wish you were like it's been my lifelong
dream to be [ __ ] ken though
you wanted like people protesting i
wanted you to no i wanted you to be like
man as a little boy i saw [ __ ] barbie
and ken i was like i want to be him man
he gets all the hot girls and you're
like and then i [ __ ] became ken
i exacted my revenge
see that would have been a great story
what are we protesting when we write the
movie when you write the movie of the
origin stories i'll do it that's how you
have to start it you have to start it
like that one indian man became a blonde
white from the sl from the slums
it's got to be some sort of bollywood
music on top on top the [ __ ] grandma
[ __ ] grandma's joining them yeah you
guys can do like bloody grandma who
wants to be a millionaire yeah exactly
you guys can come in and just dance
right across the screen your sister's
playing with [ __ ] barbie and cannon
[ __ ] and you're like a little boy you're
like oh i want to be that one then my
dad takes it and throws it in the fire
and like i can't
no you must be a doctor
you can never be you can never do
anything other than stan i could be
anything
did you ever send in voice work for ken
and you felt like they were trying to
say make it less indian
[Laughter]
it's so funny
but they said it in a different way
you know it's a note they always give me
and that i always find like can you turn
it down a little bit they're always
they're always like
ah when we're
having barbie and ken moments they're
like
that was that was too manly we need to
like turn it down a little bit yeah
that's the one note and that just kind
of depends on my brother
i went out the next that just depends on
the time of morning it's like did i have
a couple of beers last night that have
more than a couple of beers last night
like that's a good night you know and
that's when they're like hey tash can
you just light lighten it up a little
bit they're sounding a little manly
[Music]
you